[ __ ]
m
et
nous applaudit très sincèrement on sait
jamais rencontré et pourtant je vis avec
vous depuis de longues années
je vais vous montrer la photo qui est
dans mon bureau voilà je la montre avec
caméra vous la connaissez voilà voilà
avec quoi je dis pas s'arrêter à la
révolution de 1789 en effet une autre
est allé jusqu'à suit alors un 68
j'avais 19 ans donc évidemment cohn
bendit c'était moi mon idole absolue
alors mes parents sont dans la salle
aujourd'hui à l'époque qui vous aimez
moins que moi mais moi je vous adresse
maintenant c'est au kenya la malaisie
s'est calmé alors donc voilà c'est pour
vous dire à quel point on est heureux de
vous avoir parce que je vous ai toute la
journée devant les jeunes je trouve
cette photo je la remontée cette photo
est vraiment un symbole d'insolence
absolument incroyable quoi le leurs
gardes
ac c'est vraiment l'insolence est résumé
dans cette photo alors vous êtes vous
êtes assez on parle beaucoup de vous
entendre on en voit beaucoup et vous
dire les écolos imposer la journée sans
voitures mais la journée sans cohn
bendit mais moi je sais pourquoi y avait
à la main
il est à la mode parce qu'il est vous
les boues sont très à la mode
la fiq est numéro 1 du top 50 elle
s'appelle larusso c'est une rousse
axelle red est en train d'arriver numéro
un dans les connexions c'est pas vous
qui me contredirait y avait beaucoup de
rouge cette année
1 edith cresson trade à la botte de
cresson vraiment mais au fond au fond il
est gentil
alors on va faire un usage des jeunes
générations on va faire quand même après
on va parler de l'actualité on va faire
quand même hein on va parler un petit
peu un petit peu de votre vie quoi vos
parents sont arrivés d'allemagne ils
sont partis d'allemagne en 1933
1 ils sont venus en france pour des
raisons plutôt politique parce que votre
père était était de gauche donc il avait
un peu des problèmes évidemment avec le
régime qui dirige l allemagne à cette
époque là ce qui fait que chez vous
d'ailleurs on peut dire vous étiez tous
des juifs allemands l'accepter chez vous
c'était vrai alors vos parents sont
arrivés en france et vous vous êtes né à
montauban
je suis pas les gens vous le saviez vous
non j'ignorais d'une à montauban en fête
et ses parents on peut le dire
mon frère est à montrouge à montrouge
vous avez fêté vos parents ont fait
l'amour le soir du débarquement
la preuve ils ont fait l'amour peut être
aussi le soir du les versants route mais
ils ont profité de la première
possibilité biologique après le
département de faire un enfant
voilà donc quitte à sauter autant que ce
soit de cette façon là bien sûr et puis
ce qui veut dire que daniel cohn bendit
et mamans d'enfants de la liberté quand
on a été conseillé au moment du
débarquement
on ne peut qu'aimer on ne peut qu'aimer
la liberté alors on va regarder serge
khalfon si vous voulez on va regarder
quelques quelques photos daniel vous
voyez bien l'écran voyage voilà pourquoi
vous allez nous les commenter alors
voilà ça c'est vous avec votre frère
doit refaire à neuf ans de plus
si j'avais déjà le poing levé on va déjà
le poing levé sur tout bleu fip mon fils
est né quand il est sorti du ventre de
sa mère avec le poing levé aussi le
poing levé sa cg13 un nom peut-être
moins moi je sais pas c'est dur ça fait
beaucoup de sport non oui j'étais la
risée vous agissez
les joueurs disent en 2010 au donon bon
c'est la dernière fois que j'attaque
quelqu'un sur ses problèmes de poids
vous nous avez des photos des photos en
les hommes c'est le garçon qui a mis les
photos des stands sur internet
chez nous les avons dû à un macaque
honnête on est déçu mais il a eu
beaucoup moins cher et encore une photo
que je voudrais voir ça c'est le sait le
premier tgv c'est le premier arrivé sur
mon premier permis de conduire quand
vous étiez arrêté c'était une époque
difficile à ces lieux majeurs bon alors
on vous en laisse et 10 passes quand on
le voit aujourd'hui c'est un espoir pour
tout le monde
franchement non mais c'est vrai que je
prends bien regarder n'y a pas beaucoup
de différence à un peu il est surtout
resté gamin de wagons campagne
électorale je vais débuter tout sa vie
utile est gamin sam cooke d'eau qui va
aller voter pour un gamin maintenant aux
eyrieux politique et tout on a dit tout
à l'heure à ester de la vie dès qu'on
l'avait invitée parce que le 21 mars
c'était le printemps et elles forment un
couple parfait comme vous le savez ce
qui nous désole absolument avec david
hallyday
alors oui on vous a invité et ça peut
s'arranger oui
bon nombre d'invités sérieusement salmon
vous invitez parce que bas après demain
c'est le 22 mars et le 22 mars est votre
anniversaire puisque tout a commencé en
68 le 22 mars va pas refaire l'histoire
dès 60 ans
non parce que sam en fer noir cache de
68 à trouver mais pourquoi c'est pour ça
qu'on vous aime vraiment on est dans
merde et on va s'aimer puissiez ça fait
30 ans mais justement mais c'est pour ça
maintenant je vais vous dire maintenant
vous voulez d'abord il faut quand même
dire une chose en 68 qui était drôle
c'est que puisque les gens de saïx la
vie a continué à être drôle après 68 oui
maintenant quand vous avez vous quand
vous allez vous lui [ __ ] le le
ministre de la jeunesse et des sports
dans la piscine parce que les garçons
c'est rigolo rancié ce que vous dites
qu'il n'avoue jamais voulu le mettre
dans la piscine c'est ce que l'histoire
nous transcende ou non l'histoire dit
que nous avons interpellé le ministre
parce qu'il a inauguré une piscine chez
d'ailleurs plus pourquoi le way je peux
important chercher des fonds je pense
oui
non mais le problème il est là vous
arrivez directement le problème c'est à
dire qu'en fait je sais pas qui vous a
dit qu'il fallait que vous deveniez à un
type pas parler de 68 devenir un vrai
sérieux un médiateur est plus un
provocateur qui kelly l'institut de
sondage qui vous a dit ça à personne non
c'est pas ça assez que l'après froide
des fois non d'une fois des fois c'est
vrai que je provoque mais j'ai
l'impression comme ça qu'on veut me
mettre dans une cage ou dit ce type là
quoi qu'ils fassent génétiquement y
provoque ou lingettes d'aiai astérix
robbins était tombé dans un grand bassin
il était fort commun comme un buffle
oui mais moi je suis tombé dans une
bassine oui je suis provocateur quoi que
je fasse
et c'est pas tout à fait ça les noms
mais c'est pour ça qu'on vous aime c'est
ce qu'on prévoit pour qu'on voulait
gommer ce côté là je gobe mais fermez là
dedans moi je trouve c'est normal
merci ah oui c'est comme vous elle trop
de blabla non c'est comme toute personne
qui n'a pas envie d'être d'être d'être
tu vois que malgré seulement bon pour
une action ou un fait et parce que comme
des la vie continue et on évolue surtout
on voulait dire que je suis un vieux
baba et que je lui parle de 60 ans mais
tellement qu il est énorme pour ce qu'il
a fait dit elle
déclaration d'amour elle a raison je
comprends que quelqu'un me dit je t'aime
parce que j'aime 68 ou à la d'accord oui
je suis d'accord mon mais quelqu'un qui
me dit je t'aime d'affaires à 69
moi je trouve que le monde et moderne
que je t'aime bien faire un 69
ouais on disait ça il ya 30 ans à la
télé tu passais plus jamais marqué mais
si on fera un grand grande manif on va
voir ce que sont devenus beaucoup d'amis
de 68 vous les voyez là j'ai ce marc
sauvageau tout ça mais on n'est pas la
génération verdun ouais on fait qu on
essaie on n'a pas fait la guerre de 14
ans exactement mais c'est non et
justement
donc j'ai des amis j'ai des amis de
l'époque il y en a mais c'est pas parce
que j'étais à la télévision avec alain g
ce marais avec sochaux jacques way qu'on
était des des grands copains ont ils en
avaient des rôles différents
mais je rendrai à kouchner vous êtes
resté copains quand même mais je l' ai
connu après ahmad accord offrira l'orgue
on va mettre ça c'est toujours utile à
mes yeux sur le gold inc
oui
m
à
l'argent
mauvaise nouvelle ils sont tous avec
tony ah oui avec de l'est il avait fait
la marseillaise chantée plaint-il
il a fait le chant des partisans donc
avec johnny la marseillaise ça serait
pas mal pourquoi peut être vers les murs
en tout cas bah oui mais là c'était pour
mes 50 50 ans absolument ils sont bons
alors en 87
vous avez tenté une carrière vous êtes
bien fait dans le cinéma
ah oui magnette à ses vaches ça il fait
ses parts mais vraiment méchant rafa je
ne suis pas trompé sama pour toi sur un
autre plan il charrie je suis content
pour toi
aya une belle scène comme il n'a pas
pris la meilleure à mon avis oui on
prépare l'avenir
non non non ah ben oui ça c'est celle au
risque tapissent c'est loin houston mais
là ça serait de voir cet été
ouais bien s'il merzak allouache merzak
allouache une très belle scène
hewson oui deux mois non le long elle et
les deux jeunes cons très bien elle est
très très bien d'en venir pardon je peux
pas accepter c'est vrai qu'à trop si
c'est pour le voyage
t'en fais pas pour le disque je
n'enverrai la mer maintenant mais ton
pull jeté mais le métro donc c'est
effectivement je montre la casse est ce
parce que si chez vous si vous voulez
acheter ce think tank c'est un lit et
marie donc c'est un amour à paris de
merzak allouache quel casque alors ouais
faut bien l'avouer on voit dans des
cascades
ce chien c'est un fait atterrir c'est
formidable je le conseille il n'a pas vu
là les mains sont liées on a montré une
minute et demie et fait comme si les
critiques de cinéma qui ont pas pu ainsi
mais qui n'aime pas les acteurs on va
pas tuer droit on va pas non plus en rda
tout regard des normes
bien sûr ce n'est pas la peine de
rentrer et non plus quelques routes qui
parle des films sans les avoir vus eux
non ce que je voulais dire sérieusement
quand vous regardiez l'extrait là vous
vous disiez ça c'est le côté tapis quoi
c'est l'effet tapie vous à vous avez
peur d'être assimilé à tapis maintenant
c'est l'effet un peu qu'à un moment on
essaie de toucher à tout et que des fois
si on est président d'un club de foot
n'a pas besoin de faire de deux
politiques et si on fait de la politique
on n'a pas besoin de faire un cinéma
c'est cette critique là d'accord c'est
ce qu'on disait non tapisser les piles
tapis celle football tapisser la
télévision tapis c'est la politique
tapis c'est partout
enfin on en arrive aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui vous êtes tête de liste donc
des verts et vous avez déclaré sais pas
si vous avez intéresse comme aujourd'hui
vous avez déclaré en parlant des verts
je vais les sortir de leurs gonds
schisme gnangnan tu as été il ya quatre
ans alors il faut faire les notes
moi j'étais j'ai fait cette déclaration
quand les verts n'avaient pas encore
décidé de ce ancré à gauche c'était le
temps du ni ni à cet event heures et
voilà et moi j'ai la ola donc justement
est donc d'accord la médaille d'or avec
la wii bien c'est bon alors vous venez
de lui dominique voynet sympa et puis
surtout c'est vraiment une vie elle dit
elle dit en parlant de vous il est
fascinant il est émouvant et il est
d'autant plus dangereux qu'on laisserait
avoir par un tel talent je suis là ou
pas allez dis ça oui hélas pas se méfier
de moulins quand même apparemment non je
crois qu'elle est sincère elle le
ressens comme ça et je trouve que au
lieu de jouer elle dit on a envie de
faire une campagne ensemble et mais
quand bon elle a cette sincérité de dire
quand je le vois à la télé je me disais
fois tiens attention il a quelque chose
à la base il est en télé ça c'est vrai
oui puis d'un autre côté qui dérange
bombe elle le dit moi je trouve ça
vachement sympa mais savez quoi
elle devrait se faire teindre les
cheveux en rouge où elle sait qu'elle a
changé de couleur la malchance de
couleurs toutes les soirées qu'elle se
baignait à la régulière alors on a un
document là vous allez voir un document
où vous êtes avec dominique voynet
magnéto
les camions
le vent souffle sur la scène les
élections européennes la provocation il
faut dire que c'est mon domaine
dominique voilée est venu me chercher
les verts ont décidé de mener ce combat
pour le gagner pour vaincre le bc
deviner laguiller lors de la grosse
bataille a désormais sonné à moi
maintenant de défendre notre terre
contre une armée de communisme et a
croisé le fer pour prendre les élégantes
ils se croient propriétaires j'exige les
32 heures et la sortie du nucléaire
je vole au secours des sans papiers
c'est vrai je fais du zèle dominique me
donne le soir des gorges et d'hydromel
pour que je trouve la force de
contredire lionel et pour piquer les
blast 2 d'hommes et de noël ce n'est pas
la première fois pour moi que je barre
au combat j'espère en être digne et pas
me planter son foulard
dans
il
dans la
j'ai cru
seconde
il
dirigeant de gueule d'être écolo
la tribu totani 0,2 aux européennes
est-ce que vous allez voter pour les
verts aux européennes
c'est vrai que si j'avais voté j'aurais
voté pour toi je ne vote pas parce que
d'abord je suis pas encore inscrit son
avis je sais très mauvais citoyens et
puis en fait je me sens je ne veux tu
veux pas inscrivez vous en fin mais ça
c'est incroyable parce qu'il ya des pays
où on est automatiquement inscrits 1 sur
cette histoire d'aller s'inscrire ou à
moi déjà je trouve ça rébarbatif et en
plus tu peux si de six mois s'il me
prend l'envié d'aller 13 juin via les 13
juin et j'irai avec mon passeport ils
ont intérêt à prendre mon bâton
oui surtout si c'est pour moi un bon
courtisan manif l'a redit que le vent le
13 juin
joie et 10 passes jeu et 10 juin mais
pas les joints du 10 juin au 10 juin
une déformation professionnelle est ce
que vous feriez pour délit cohn-bendit
bien sûr mais moi j'avais une petite
question juste à vous poser comme ses
alliés sur le nombre d'années
vous êtes allé toujours au front que ça
soit crs en face où je sais pas je
savais pas où machin est ce que vous
avez pris beaucoup de retard
l'été approche même la photo ici
alors mettez là le téléphone du dentiste
73 ans ah oui ça pourrait avoir des
contrats il est fort non mais le truc
c'est que quand tu te tu t'approches
tout seul flic tu prends jamais parce
que ça et 6 y attend pas moi j'ai jamais
j'ai pas de gardes du corps et des
choses comme ça moi je crois en
l'insolence de la non-violence et donc
je m'approche des gens et même quand
j'étais à l'aamm dit bonjour
et c'est vrai que les types ils
voulaient me casser la figure et en même
temps il était complètement étonné qu'un
type d'image bien on discute et moi je
suis c'est vrai il faut dissuader côté
gandhi passionnant avec parce que
justement il était face à evans
il était prêt à lâcher quoi c'était
assez facilement que ne l'aurait fait
pas j'hésite encore mais j'ai encore une
émission avec lui et il fait partie des
fossiles fait partie des manuels pour
vous inscrire à voter pour daniel
mais ce qu'on a le droit d'inscrire
encore non c'est jusque là jusqu'à ce
qu'on a le nom mais c'est l'organisation
administrative que je ne vois je veux
dire corps musclé président de la
république on pourra s'inscrire quand on
veut et même après
pas comme tiberi même ceux qui sont pas
des vieux les morts bon alors ce temps
là on les donne objectivement même
faussement pompage de musique moi c'est
que vous êtes passé de 9% à 5%
daniel dans les années à chantonnay ce
qu'on peut quand même se à s'insérer ce
sondage était un sondage bibi zar
c'était un sondage sofres et il ya
d'autres sondages on est entre 7 et 8%
et à trois quatre mois des élections
c'est vrai que les 6es problème d'image
etc
mais le sondage de 5% est bizarre parce
que le mdc était à 4% en 2011 dans le
parti donc je veux dire mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu une forêt c'était le
romantisme est allé dany revient merci
c'est bien et puis après bon on se pose
des questions on est pour lui pour
l'europe mais pas tout à fait pour lui
sur le nucléaire on épure lui sur le
écologisme quand même sur l'europe il va
loin
donc il faut que les jeunes les choses
se clarifient est dans la campagne se
méfier des bruits de chiottes survivre
quelques un communiqué contre la chasse
et pour les sans papiers
globalement pour but de tout à l'heure
votre nouveau avant le slogan c'était ce
n'est qu'un début continuons le combat
et maintenant c'est ce n'est qu'un début
continuons le débat est ce que vous ayez
pas peur de ce côté médiateur par
opposition au côté provocateur qui votre
image est ce que c'est parce beaucoup de
des voix finalement c'est à ce côté
vouloir fédérer le plus grand nombre de
gens est-ce que vous avez pas peur ça
vous coûte des voix c'est ça le problème
aujourd'hui vraie question mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui dans une société bloquée
angoissé comme la nôtre en france le
débat est une provocation
la preuve c'est que les gens n'ont peur
de dire une campagne électorale c'est
pas que chacun aille dans son préau
prêcher pour sa chapelle
bon moi j'ai 800 700 900 personnes dans
un d'endémie team je leur dis vive les
verts ils disent bien sûr on est là pour
ça hein ça serait bien plus intéressant
qu'on fasse des meetings monsieur pasqua
et moi monsieur seguin et moi monsieur
hollande et monsieur seguin donc qu'il y
ait un enjeu dans un meeting politique
au lieu de racht sera ramaré les mêmes
histoires injures par rapport à arlette
laguiller comme elle reste est pure et
dure
oui mais c'est une secte moi je dis rien
c'est une secte l amp est avec rejetons
pas le truc moi - par exemple celui qui
reste est pure idiot je suis pas
d'accord mais j'étais pas d'accord avec
lui à 30 ans pas la tribune c'est alain
krivine
c'est vrai que lui il a une et pilar une
organisation que c'est pour ça que le
pacs arlette
la me paraît pas un pacs disons c'est
pas le mdax honnête dans le sens que ces
deux de deux sens de la politique c'est
lorsqu'il dit vous krivine widi d'aider
mes chances non éduqué le talent gâché
oui mais je serai mais lui c'est quel
talent qui n'a pas su se mettre au
service d'une vraie politique réformiste
votre programme est assez hard soft
attendait le rmi pour tous les gens
jusqu'à 25 ans le rembarre leurs entrées
des lycées société année l'europe
fédéraliser la cruciale
je dis pas je suis content que l'on ait
choisi d'axer pas bien mais l'europe
fédéraliste d'être le seul à le dire
quoi on voit bien qu'on va vers ça non
il ya même l'ami berrou qui essayent de
temps à temps dit moi aussi je suis pour
ouais c'est tout bon faux lui faut le
dire il faut être sympa avec ceux qui
essayent d'avoir décidé bon et alors on
n'a rien fait de bégaiement de beroun
autrement dit passagers fait pas a fait
part d'un data là c'est pour toi la
pacific princess
oui donc notre ami daniel et pour la
légalisation du cannabis
et ben moi nous parce que légaliser
quelque chose qui est quand même une
drogue faut savoir je suis pour être
divine et moi je faisais mais là je suis
pour une nouvelle réglementairement
aussi voilà là on est d'accord année
j'ai fait râler sur une régulation c'est
une règle il faut il faut pas jouer sur
les mots quels savoirs tant de nos
monuments
oui d'accord mais quand on a les galères
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire du reggae
sans fumée de pétards non mais bien sûr
avant les gens qui font du ring oui mais
il appelait les gens qui fument des
pétards et qui font pas de règle c'est
vrai qu'à écouter
écouter du reggae et voter du reggae en
ayant fumé
c'est aussi bien que de bien manger en
buvant un verre de vin mais justement
c'est d'abord la voix chacun serge
khalfon magnéto l'avantagent entre
bernard et moi c'est moi je suis pas
ministre mais parfois un amant et donc
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure il ya aucun
problème
le cannabis fait partie maintenant de la
culture de jouissance en europe
on aime ou n'aime pas si on mange bien
on doit bien boire
le problème c'est il ne faut pas
conduire et boire il ne faut pas fumer
et conduire que quand même pas laisser
passer ça j'viens
pas moi